before I start wanting to let you guys
know inshallah I am trying to raise 500
000 meals from Muslim Aid please please
guys go to the link and give these
people are starving imagine you help
them have iftaran sisters imagine the
reward that you will get do check that
out in the link in the description box
below inshallah we're gonna get straight
into this video
brothers and sisters can you imagine
someone struggling and he has downloaded
the Quran app and built a habit and now
he's regularly reading you can go into
the description box click the link for
IOS and Android and build your habit
with the Quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
about 11 12 years ago I can remember
when I was looking into Islam there were
some videos that I used to watch about
conspiracy theories and Etc all that
kind of stuff about Illuminati the end
of times I was very very intrigued by
these videos I can remember one specific
video which was talking about basically
that the government is going to try to
control us on mass Levels by putting a
chip in our hands now back then I was
thinking
um maybe maybe not but who would go and
intentionally get a chip in their hand
you know nobody's going to do that see
the thing is Obama sisters what you
start to learn is things don't work that
simple of course the government knows
you're not going to go and be like hey
put a chip in my hand so you can control
me it's not going to happen like that
what's really bizarre is that recently
2019 a man volunteered I think so I
wanted to do that he actually got a chip
in his hand which was just bigger than a
grain of rice and he could make payments
with this and vice versa and many many
stuff with it and I'm sure his details
were all on that now the question that
needs to be asked is in 10 years or 12
years 11 years a lot of things have
changed people's psychology works in
different ways if you look at covid and
how it spread and whatever it may be
brother and sister subhanallah you can
very very clearly see that if the
government wanted to do something they
would do it now that'll be done in
different ways yeah okay I don't know
what that is the point I'm trying to
make is sometimes we look at this
conspiracy theories and be like ah
whatever and then we end up even though
we're laughing we end up being laughed
at when we realize that it is coming to
me now this can be a step towards the
degelic system brothers and sisters
because one of the signs of the uh of
the child is that the prophet peaceful
said that he would not be talked about
in the members in the hot bus and I
don't remember the last time that I went
to Enterprise I started speaking I heard
him heard about
now this can be a form because he's
going to have great power and control
the masses at large yeah so if a time
comes where we are told to have these
trips for God knows whatever reasons
health reasons or whatever it may be and
that shows that if they want to turn it
off and leave you broke especially by
them getting rid of money paper money
they have
massive massive control over us from
sisters that they can just turn it off
if you do not obey what they say you
cannot buy anything you cannot go
anywhere you cannot travel anywhere and
you are literally imprisoned
that's what I have to say guys and mail
us a panel trying to protect us and be
amongst those who fight against rather
than joining him may Allah protect us
and the only way we will fight against
him and be protected by him but he says
is if you live by Islam and if you
service them and you submit your will to
Islam don't think any weapon or Atomic
weapons or whatever you think you can
have is going to protect you towards him
it's only by the finish of Allah and by
his book the Quran and the Sunnah that
you'll be protected may Allah protect us
from that fitna I'll see you guys next
time